PERIPHERALLY AWARE OF THE DEAL.
>> Bret: STANDBY IF YOU WOULD
DO, LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE COHEN LEAK.
JOINING US FROM NEW YORK, JUDGE
ANDREW NAPOLITANO.
HE SAYS I WAS A BUSINESSMAN I
WAS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, I CAN
DO THIS.
THE DEAL NEVER CAME AROUND, IT
DIDN'T MATERIALIZE.
WHERE IS THE THREAT TO THE
PRESIDENT IN THIS PARTICULAR
DEVELOPMENT?
SPEAK OF THE STATEMENTS THE
PRESIDENT MADE WHICH YOU JUST
SUMMARIZED ARE ALL PROBABLY TRUE
AND THEY DON'T REFLECT ANYTHING
UNLAWFUL, BUT THE DANGER FOR HIM
IS WHATEVER MICHAEL COHEN TOLD
BOB MUELLER'S INVESTIGATORS IN
THE 70 HOURS THAT THEY DEBRIEFED
HIM SOMETIME IN THE PAST THREE
OR FOUR MONTHS.
AT THE LAST TIME HE PLEADED
GUILTY THE PROSECUTING ENTITY
WAS THE FEDERAL PROSECUTORS HERE
IN NEW YORK IN THE SAME
COURTHOUSE.
TODAY WHEN HE PLEADED GUILTY, IT
WAS BOB MUELLER'S TEAM WHICH
CAME FROM WASHINGTON, D.C.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT MICHAEL COHEN
GAVE BOB MUELLER IN RETURN FOR
REDUCING HIS EXPOSURE FOR MANY
YEARS IN JAIL DOWN TO SIX
MONTHS.
THAT'S THE DANGER TO THE
PRESIDENT.
WE MAY NEVER KNOW.
IT DEPENDS HOW BOB MUELLER WANTS
TO USE IT.
MICHAEL:  COHEN IS NOT SOMEBODY
BOB MUELLER IS GOING TO PUT ON
THE WITNESS STAND BUT HE CAN
TAKE THE INFORMATION THEY GAVE
HIM AND IF HE CAN CORROBORATE IT
THROUGH A CREDIBLE SOURCE, USE
IT THEREAFTER.
>> Bret: THAT'S IMPORTANT.
TO JUDGE HIS POINT, YOU'RE
LOSING CREDIBILITY ONE YEAR
CHARGING SOMEONE WITH A LYING.
THESE GUYS AREN'T EXACTLY THE
BEST WITNESSES IF YOU'RE
BRINGING A CASE FORWARD BUT WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE MUELLER
HAS.
>> THE CRITICISM OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL AS THESE ARE ALL
PROCESSED CRIMES, THESE ARE ALL
LYING TO FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS,
LYING TO CONGRESS, I'M NOT
MINIMIZING THAT BUT IT DOESN'T
GO TO THE CORE ISSUE OF THE
ALLEGATION OF COORDINATION
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS.
SOMETHING THAT CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION TODAY IS THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD BE PROSECUTED FOR LYING
TO CONGRESS BUT OTHER
INDIVIDUALS AT THE HEART OF THE
RUSSIA CASE SUCH AS CHRISTOPHER
STEELE WHO IS THE AUTHOR OF THE
TRUMP DOSSIER, HE IS THE SUBJECT
OF A CRIMINAL REFERRAL FROM THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
GLENN SIMPSON OF FUSION GPS, HIS
FIRM WAS PLAYED BY THE DNC DID
WITH THE DOSSIER TOGETHER AND HE
HAS PROBLEMATIC TESTIMONY TO
CONGRESS, PUBLICLY WE HAVEN'T
SEEN ANY ACTION ON THOSE CASES.
COHEN IS THE FIRST PERSON WE SAY
PAY A PENALTY.
>> Bret: IT SEEMS LIKE THIS IS
COMING TO A HEAD.
IT SEEMS PERHAPS MUELLER AND HIS
TEAM HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT MATT
WHITAKER THE ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
MAYBE SOME OF THESE COURT
FILINGS ARE ABOUT GETTING THE
STORY AS THEY SEE IT OUT TO --
JUST IN CASE THE REPORT DOESN'T
MAKE IT THROUGH WHITAKER AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
IN EXAMINING THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
RULES, IT'S INTERESTING.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL DOESN'T NEED
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHITAKER'S APPROVAL TO DO
ANYTHING, HE MERELY MUST INFORM
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL MATT
WHITAKER OF WHAT HE IS GOING TO
DO, WHICH WE GATHER FROM THE
REPORTING OF OUR COLLEAGUES
JOHN ROBERTS IT HAPPENED LAST
NIGHT AT THE SAME TIME THE
WHITE HOUSE LEARNED OF THIS.
YOU ARE CORRECT, A LOT OF THINGS
HAVE HAPPENED SINCE THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS AND THIS HAS BEEN A
CRITICAL WEEK.
I DON'T THINK WE'VE SEEN THE END
OF THIS.
I DESCRIBED WHAT HAPPENED IN
COURT THIS MORNING -- IT'S A
TRITE PHRASE BUT I THINK IT'S
ACCURATE -- OF THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG.
BOB MUELLER KNOWS WHAT THE REST
OF THE ICEBERG IS, MICHAEL COHEN
KNOWS WHAT THE REST OF THE
ICEBERG IS.
MUELLER WILL DECIDE WHEN TO LET
THE REST OF US KNOW.
>> Bret: IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERYTHING WENT A LITTLE BIT
MORE FAST FORWARD AFTER THE
PRESIDENT FILED THE ANSWERS TO
THOSE QUESTIONS WHICH INCLUDED
ONE ABOUT THIS REAL ESTATE DEAL.
>> I THINK THAT WAS ONE OF THE
BIG REVELATIONS TODAY ABOUT
THOSE QUESTIONS, HE DID ASK
ABOUT A PROPOSAL TO BUILD A
TOWER IN MOSCOW BY THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION.
UP UNTIL NOW IT WAS NOT KNOWN TO
US THROUGH OUR REPORTING AND
WHAT RUDY GIULIANI THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY SAID TO US
TODAY, THEY DON'T SEE ANY
CONTRADICTION BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT'S WRITTEN ANSWERS AND
WHAT WAS STATED IN THE COHEN
PLEA.
THEY STILL FEEL COMFORTABLE BUT
THE TIMING WHEN YOU LINE UP THE
DATA POINTS CERTAINLY HAS THE
FEEL OF ALMOST A CASCADING OR
DOMINO EFFECT.
>> Bret: JUDGE, WE'VE SEEN ALL
KINDS OF REPORTING HERE, THERE'S
NEW REPORTING RIGHT NOW, BUT
SWEET HAS A STORY SAYING
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S COMPANY
PLANNED TO GIVE A $50 MILLION
PENTHOUSE AT TRUMP TOWER MOSCOW
TO VLADIMIR PUTIN AS THE COMPANY
NEGOTIATED THE LUXURY
REAL ESTATE DEVELOPMENT
ACCORDING TO FOUR PEOPLE.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT INDEPENDENTLY
CONFIRMED, WE'VE SEEN OTHER
STORIES FALL APART.
WE WILL BE ABOUT THIS BUT IS THE
ARGUMENT THAT THE NEGOTIATION --
EVEN IF HE IS DOING A BUSINESS
DEAL -- AS IT'S HAPPENING WITH A
HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER AS HE IS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT THAT
EVENTUALLY BECOMES PRESIDENT,
THAT IT IS POTENTIALLY SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE HELD OVER THE HEAD
OF THE PRESIDENT BY RUSSIA?
>> THE PRESIDENT'S STATEMENT
TODAY, YOU RAN THE CLIP OF IT
EARLIER WITH JOHN ROBERTS IN
WHICH HE SAID WHAT'S THE BIG
DEAL?
THIS IS A DEAL WE DIDN'T DO.
I THINK HE'S ON VERY SOLID
GROUND THERE.
THE PROBLEM WILL COME IF, FOR
EXAMPLE, MICHAEL COHEN SAYS THE
PRESIDENT TOLD ME TO LIE AND I
LIED BEFORE THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE BECAUSE
HE AND I DECIDED TO CONCOCT A
SCHEME TO TRICK PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHERE THE PRESIDENT WILL
BE IMPALED.
NOT DOING A DEAL NO MATTER HOW